bonjour on est bien dans on n'est pas
sorti de l'auberge
à partir d'aujourd'hui c'est moi qui
dirige les missions alors on est
aujourd'hui à dos d'âne à la ferme
bellevue
c'est monsieur jacky chab et
s'accompagne hélas les a30 donne manger
animaux depuis grand matin en hongrie
short fatigue et raisonnée qui
prédisaient libre bonjour jacky comment
il est à bonjour bien à la santé les
mollahs dans les faibles alors expliquer
non un petit peu d'activité si on laisse
te plaît ben moi mon activité c'est que
à moyen terme un bon démarrage nous la
mettons en place un projet et tables
d'hôtes et a prôné la d autres écoles
d'ici mais c'est un projet table 2 to
gain ils pouvaient alors isamu type et
la tradition qui aurait lyonnaise et la
culture lyonnaise a en même temps dans
son chouette ça les chouettes et donc
l'ami whaou avec un saut il ya du pain à
l'intérieur je baisse mon talent un
petit coup la carie d'opale - départ à
paris - des milliers - bolton aux
bandits montagne qui coule baisse et
l'amazone badji c'est un blond
d'aquitaine
comment il s'appelle maso major enchanté
l'agent carrier recteur règlement
élaboré caporali caporal intime aux
cayes a coincé vous c'est pourquoi
l'activité les parents gémissements
nommément aux passions ses saveurs
toute famille c'est l'été en famille ça
attise se fait ça va être mes mots et
vos passions ses 129
l'idée c'est d'être à étudier un tube
pied pitié et dépouillé par ali comme ça
qu'on s'adresse en retrait d'alvaro pour
la place la relève la relève
bakou
saâdane volaille a vu marie allons
allons
je te suis mon cher sa magie pour
volailles banana de l'espèce on a deux
fermiers on à tana moins six mois la
majorité m'ont reproduction ses poumons
table d'autres convient là où les rois
de l'ogou pays
j'ai bien mon père quand on joue à mon
canon mon volaille
toutefois la fin c'est vous heureusement
insurmontable de généraux de l'ogou pays
le groupe émaillent le groupe est hélas
le matin tu as partie ce qui est le à la
dent dans la basse cour qui relève d'un
café cni vous file à ce que la doxa du
réveil du bonheur a donné lieu à karachi
c'est clair 30 euros ne faut pas trop
dormi et tard le soir
le soir nous sommes le soir mais moderne
et tournaisis c'était un ennemi lui tire
d'alison des années de rations bull en 8
à pomy bec des oiseaux
hu
me réveille comme après mottaki conduit
quand même
ouais normalement mois normalement me
voit il à paris - la vague en moyenne
ils braillent mais salon souk ou encore
zazie mollet pour un seul bémol en
retard ou connais m'ont même dit en
passant ne doit pas se manger raconte en
voilà et du vin bien s'ils allaient
charette cd fourrage de 2 dans les
parages même sa phrase il combine des
coupes quand la machine
voilà un mot de cambronne ça pour aller
battre pas savouré marion
salah aux orres 11 ans 11 ans la gagne
aux ors du 8 octobre
d'accord et l'autre à bas le mur à
alizay dessin et griot battue
alors jacques diamant ticoulat me sens
nice mais comment s'en tienne tu le
doigt là où ça nous arrive nous là mais
la loi et la cuisine et loire françois
le mot madame c est le chef cuistot la
radio elle fr parmi les st-louis a bon
dos et le chef moka et c'est le chef
cuistot
voilà l'un des corps de mme anne
françoise bonjour madame
comment allez vous françoise nous deux
côtés de cuisine faite de bois
oui notamment un petit peu comme ça où
ça fait le reste plus alors là nous ça
va faire un bon suivi canard vous faites
bras avec le grain poids et à rima est
une trouvaille piments tomates du côlon
dont le même si un petit peu mais fait
toujours d'une grande marmite
parce que même bien comment car il est
bien et prend 15 épices les parents
passaient donc voilà c'est pour ça me
fait rire ou commence pas quoi mais
supposent les épices plus haut de ses
oignons de cela les épices et après
faire revenir un petit peu le canada
dans l'huile kamala quoi canal a peur
mais que demander niais et combien
tomates ou matin dans 'la selon le
canard omettre de matoub est pas pas
trop d'antiviraux même s'il est ce que
on a besoin d'un petit coup de main ah
ben oui du coup madonna aux épices qui
fait allons allons les china is one you
aller à la maintenance tard
ils vont traduire mois que l'autre
épices ou mettre dedans alors lie à mon
soutien jambes et un petit peu droff
fois un petit peu de muscade du scot est
le seul vin élevé au 10 avril
alès dont la maintenance et on va faire
revenir un peu le le canard dans l'huile
le canon le cas nord et des mines a
offert les bons les bons le bon le bon
ben on va vous la saison c'est un petit
peu un goût des places et devient rouge
yeux mais huawei est un bon cv tamar mes
coups ça au fait de manger pour deux
morizet le cari poulet
s'il veut pas de cochon qui est trop
facile aux caries mais à la demande par
iti jacques proulx blythe aussi bien la
tradition oui
alors maintenant que le cabinet au feu
et que françoise y occupe de fini et ça
nous va retrouver monsieur jacky de
l'autre côté qui va nous préparer un
petit gîte la naturelle explique hanno
un petit peu qu'est ce qui se passe mais
ça mon team racing nord ça faisait un
petit bijou âgées pour une usine comme
dirait que tout va dès lors plus facile
allez out manivelle les beauty il reste
par battement il a alors un petit peu
essoufflé mais bon zaki diament qu'on
saura si son nom là est-ce qu'on rajoute
des choses
ou alors le jus de canne de prêts à être
consommés comme salarié es les bots you
même si justin
ce n'est pas moi qui me fais ce bisou
maintenant ma place lavault de lancement
jacky après manger donc brillamment g6v
lundi - alex allons faire un petit toit
afin toit de charette et ça c'est un
truc que je ne veux pas rater
mais si jacques et moi aimons passion
selon saint valbert n'y voit pas moins
vive sens de mon sens la tête mon beauf
à parakou madame égouts des marmailles
la peau psn pass devance un bestiau plus
tôt plusieurs langues l'a toujours été
ben mais ça c'est langage énéral dégâts
immédiats tout ça à thiais la réunion
comparé par exemple aux mythes want want
want siddiqui
danyel waro l'a vraiment joli c'est
simone s'arracher la réunion abidal mais
encore sa boule d'amont main les mots
d'habitation pour des parcs et zago
camaro nos habitations pour réparer
d'avocats marron ou gris
jacques mayoux on les dernières pentes
maintien bouffer année d'assises boga
boga diallo fin mattia bouffer en est à
six banques à bourgoin on les derniers
portent la main de sang dont la fille
qui citait des moins mauvaises ravel
mozart est la fille qui citait à - mambé
wagon s'arrête côté magasin au ca de la
fait au moins la 10è ryan city gas
épicerie comme l a dit serge llado city
oovoo govou jacques mayoux oublie
raconte comment un petit peu l'idée
comment la développer pour des faits de
manger ou des moules pour fait découvrir
hot cette partie de la culture
réunionnaise la cie en l'air et au
débilité la passion aux a faibli de
paradigme et la daurade india non venue
de métier ensemble
pourquoi oula oula développement
d'activités à dos d'âne vraiment illégal
et mener à bien les gars les membres et
mais comme vous verrez plupart à tous le
développement la modernisation
l'évolution il convient bien sûr à voir
aller et comme tout le monde un problème
puis longuement neves iv big oui mais
midi il fallait tout un outil leur droit
mais un bon camarade demandé bénévoles
et agricoles il patine dia place il
pourra aussi écouter s'annonce compliqué
à mettre en place et l'anglais will à
courir effet combien de temps à cette
activité là madame t elle mais depuis
2006 mais recommandent cassé brisé
boogie mètres du but mais après des 1000
depuis 2009 nous a dit à l'ap roland
plaire et la zone des bleus le lot
d'histoires site internet
cela dit oui
jackie amy winehouse y bâtit paillote
bonnecaze longtemps l'a donc pareil
c'est miss mais suppose que l'ailier une
demande qu'il a eue le gazon pas ici
puisqu'on marque un petit peu l'image
traditionnelle créole qu'on fait la
table créole la table d'accueil au loup
a fait des petits gaz et le banc des
droitiers objets lontan
il travaille paie l'histoire l'image
lorsque la dent il veut dire beaucoup de
scanbuy relais le peuplement de l'île
les aveugles et les esclaves africains
et malgaches
jacky mais due au revoir c'est un
plaisir qu'on est à eau avaient partagé
un plaisir de voir un petit peu de
travail et tout cet amour qui donne
notre travail mais conseille à tout le
monde de venir
et ben voilà prochainement la bombe
majors ne retrouve est bon c'est leur
regrettée du départ on va retrouver le
tumulte et des bas alors y'a pas à
deviner si vous voulez venir manger un
bon quart est fait de bois
si vous voulez faire un tour en
charrette boeuf avec jacky goûter un
petit peu la cuisine de françoise c'est
ici que ça se passe à la ferme de
bellevue à dos d'âne je vous conseille
de venir ici pour voir les alentours
mafate etc des bébêtes des sentiers moi
je repars le coeur léger
mais le ventre bien plein salut